hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i thought i'd just take a
minute to answer the question that i
always get asked which is
why do i run a training company if i'm
making so much money in property and
real estate
if i'm making millions of pounds in my
business then why would i take the time
to put out videos to teach people to run
a training company what is the purpose
behind it
am i doing it for a little bit of side
income am i doing it because
i just love doing it am i doing it
because like what's the what's the
actual
truth behind why i do what i do so i
thought i'd just
tell you in this video so i'm going to
be 100 transparent i want to be 100
i'm gonna tell you the back story tell
you why i run a training company
and um yeah i hope this is helpful i
hope this gives you a little bit of
insight as to
the man behind the youtube videos so
i started out in property in 2001 2008
2009 i bought my first house
and you've probably seen it documented
um i
then bought when i was age 19 i did
lease option agreements some joint
ventures i borrowed some money off my
grandma
and i started just growing my portfolio
started from scratch
using all the strategies that i teach
now on youtube so lease option
agreements joint ventures hmos
um buy refurbished refinance all the
strat
all these strategies that's how i built
my portfolio
now when i was uh 20 years old i
um was actually to give a little bit of
context when i
started property in the first place i
was a teenager i had to leave my dad's
company
my dad had a children's entertainment
agency and he was upset with me for
leaving the company and he was like
you're leaving the family business what
are you doing
and he actually fell out with me and it
was
it was really quite hard starting out in
property
and um i then actually became a
christian
and i joined the church in warsaw and my
pastor of the church was almost like a
father figure to me like a spiritual
father
so that's a little bit of context okay
now when i'm 20
and i've got quite a lot of properties
i'm doing really really well my
pastor started
having quiet conversations with me about
making lots of money so
he'd be um at the front of the church
preaching
and he'd be saying things like you know
a rich person getting into heaven is
like a camel
getting through the eye of a needle and
he'd certainly be looking at me
and i'd be like whoa um you know you
can't serve god and money
you need to choose you're gonna serve
god or you're gonna serve money
and i begin to i began to feel like
almost like a little bit of a guilt
complex around
having lot more than one house even
though i was given 10
of my um my money i was i was given to
the church and to charities and to
people in need
um i was sponsoring kids inc um via
compassion
you know i wasn't like a greedy trying
to get really rich
i was just growing my portfolio because
i'd learned how to do that from mentors
and training programs and networking
events
and i was put into practice and i was
flourishing
however when i was 20 i got a guilt
complex and i went to
um i i decided to i also had a
bad car accident as well um my car
crushed and
i was like man life's so short my pastor
is like a spiritual father too he's
misunderstanding me
and i thought you know what i wanted to
spend a few years i've made some decent
money
i've got a little portfolio i've got
rents coming in i just want to study
myself
i want to learn about um the ethics of
business
and i um as a christian somebody that
was really involved in the church
i spent three years and i went to bible
college birmingham bible institute
and at bible college i studied theology
and
after three years i wrote a little
dissertation on biblical economics
and i came to the conclusion that
actually making money isn't a good thing
or a bad thing it's a neutral thing
it just depends on what you do with your
money and
i realize that you can't serve god and
money but you can serve god through
money
i realized that being rich didn't mean
that you were a jerk or a bad person
in fact money doesn't change you it just
exposes who you truly are and if you've
got a good heart and you want to help
people
having money will mean that you can do
that even more so it would just magnify
who you actually
are as a result of that when i left
barbara college i did it
yeah when i was 20 21 22 i was full time
at barber college when i finished
barbara college age 22
i just thought you know what i don't
want to be a pastor
or a minister i want to be
a businessman and i want to reach people
and i wanna
so i had to cut the video my wife was
calling me saying that she'd we're
actually at hospital right now this is
the hence all the baby stuff
nothing bad what was going on oh we just
had a baby we just had a baby
and we had to have a prick yeah yeah it
was a five day checkup
oh that's this is my wife amanda in fact
i'm just telling the story i'm just
gonna
is it right to finish the video real
quick real quick when we met
what i was actually just finishing
barber clubs like what was happening
what was i doing at the time
um you'd also just launched training
things yep
training things training kings was a
christian business network and this was
like about 2015
2014 2014 2014 yeah 2014.
you're actually doing lots of speaking
engagements at churches and stuff as
well
yep um and you had your property stuff
but you hadn't told me the extent as to
what
so at the time because he just finished
bible college and he was doing training
things
i just assumed that he was going down we
were going down the church route and you
were going to be a pastor
right and now he's going to be a
pastor's wife very very wrong
in a church yeah so that's that's
yesterday and then i told you about the
property stuff later yeah yeah
you knew a little bit about it i knew a
little bit about it but not not yeah
not how big it was yeah yeah and here's
the thing right when i met amanda
i could be i left i left barber college
right i met amanda
i didn't want to go on about my property
stuff and i also i didn't want
to attract people for the wrong reasons
okay so you know so i did have a big
property portfolio when i left bible
college but i was really focusing on
you know on training kings what was
training kings
christian business network it was um
there to connect christians in business
it was exclusive but yeah so here's
here's what happened okay so i built a
property portfolio
went to bible college continued doing
property but kind of did it quietly
went to bible college studied learned
about biblical economics
learn actually money is not good or bad
it's just at all i became released
from the guilt of earning money and i
thought actually you know what money's a
certificate of thanks
if i can provide affordable
accommodation for people you know
there's
limited houses in the uk being a
property investor is actually a really
good honorable thing
making money being a businessman is an
honorable thing so i decided to go crazy
on my property business
i started selling a lot of deals right
yep like packaging and selling deals
that's how i became a millionaire
but i also wanted i had a heart to help
people
from from the church because i'd seen
myself from the church i thought i'd
been misunderstood
there was this whole idea that you
couldn't make money and be a good person
so i set up the training kings which is
a christian business network to connect
christian business people
well i'm so actually it's okay to make
money because i actually want to see
entrepreneurs i want to see people
making loads of money that are generous
they don't hold it like this
their wealth and their knowledge and
everything like this they hold
everything with open hands and a
generous heart that's what i wanted to
see
so i thought you know what if i've
learned how to make lots of money
most rich people hide away they're
speaking riddles they hide away
they don't tell people how they did it
or what they're doing i thought i'm
gonna share
i'm gonna so i was doing it but training
kings by the way for the record
training kings was non-for profit like i
would charge
remember how much it was on the door for
training kings was it ten pounds ten
pounds literally just to cover their
food
things yeah ten pounds feed them give
them
how to pay for a hotel so training king
started losing me money
okay so i'm teaching people i'm sharing
with people i'm trying
i wrote a book called do the possible
watch god do the impossible
and and i'm trying to help and inspire
people from my church and from other
churches
and it's costing me money to train and
to do this
i lost money as training kings was
costing me 4 000 pounds a month
and sounds like a lot of money but i was
paying for it out of my property
business
so my property business we weren't
living a luxurious lifestyle we were
living
in like a like a three-bed detached
house in
a nice part of warsaw lived a decent
life but i was using my profits to pay
for training kings we started going on
mission trips started going to africa
zimbabwe um you know you're born and
bred in zimbabwe
we went to zambia what did we do in
zambia we did um some mission work
um provided some boreholes to um some
villages that were lacking clean water
let's just start you know really with
the money that we're making through
property
really helping people me and amanda got
married in 2015
and um and what happened was training
kings really grew so we set up 14
branches across the uk
but it was costing me more and more
money to run it but i just saw it as a
way of giving back
training kings 2014 lost 2015 lost money
2016 lost money
2017 lost money to end of 2016 that's
when i started um
what happened was people started saying
to me hey um samuel they were coming to
training kings but they had no intent
they weren't bothered about
the christian aspect or they weren't
bothered about the whole guilt complex
they were just like we want to pick
someone's brain about property
so a lot of people started coming to
training kings they were just asking me
how did you actually
make money and i'd say well i made money
from lease option agreements from joint
ventures from property from hmos that's
how i make money and everyone
asked me all these questions about
property and i thought i don't want
training kings
christian business network to become
training kings aka property teaching
so i set up a separate company samuel is
limited
2016 which was a property training
company
and and again i did this just because i
had so many people asking me
um set that up in 2016 and um that just
blew up
the training the training companies blew
up and the results
that people started getting from the
property training people become
financially free
i thought man this is amazing people the
the word spread
people started flying in overseas to
come and meet me thousands and thousands
of people
so um so that's how i'm a trainer that's
why i'm a trainer
and i you know i've i've got more
success students now i think a lot of
people may be going to training to try
and make money
as a trainer i actually don't make any
money even now as a trainer
my training companies lost me money more
years than made money
if the training company loses money i
foot the bill
if it makes money i take nothing from it
so
i don't take any money from training i
do it as a passion project
and the day i'll stop training is the
day i stop
getting the same satisfaction from my
students succeeding but at the moment
we've got people every week coming on
winners on a wednesday and
sharing their story and it's not just
that i'm helping people make money i'm
helping people make money but i'm
changing their lives and also there then
being able to fulfill their missions
and and you know a lot of charities and
social enterprises that have been set up
as a result of
good hearted people being becoming
financially free as
a result of my training so that's kind
of the full story how the training
company started
um what it's doing now at the moment
we've got a lot of training that we've
run online
i run some of it physically um i put a
lot of free stuff
out on youtube that's the story won't be
possible without this lady
because i'll tell you something when i
when we first got married i was i was
planning on quitting the training right
yeah we got married and i'm like right
now i want to just you know let's just
retire and
live a quiet life and um what was it
like me being on paternity for
four months oh my goodness he didn't
know what to do with himself
yeah just yeah you just missed it you
lost that buzz well yeah because
when when we had our first childhood
this is our third when we had our first
child
um ruby i said i might take six months
off after about two months mandy was
like
you need to go back to work you need to
go buy more houses and
you know sell more deals the deal
packaging business that made
a lot of money still does today um and
amanda was just like you know what
you need to just be helping people
training people
and busy because i was just like did not
do myself at home yeah you're in your
element when you're helping people
you're passionate about it's your
mission yeah i get the same buzz of
someone else getting
a deal when i've helped them do it than
when i got my first deal so you know
that's it anyway folks that's the story
it's a wrap let's go home and enjoy some
uh enjoy some family time